I'm sick I'm grace and both of those are
true hi guys my name is Chris Apogee
know now you know your life is different
now it really took the last couple days
and I completely lost my voice in last
three days only today is it's starting
to feel better so I thought let's
continue to ruin it by just talking a
lot in the video and you know when
you're sick you just want to sit in your
bed you don't want to get out my brain
wanted me to get out of bed of my body
didn't so I thought I would do something
to get myself out of bed may I say
something that might drag me out of bed
but yeah your back looks great walking
away from this YouTube channel who's
your trainer I've done a drag makeup
tutorial here before and it turned out
surprisingly well but but let's do it
again I looked up a bunch of tutorials
and I decided I wanted to try to
recreate another one - fame who has the
greatest YouTube channel if you haven't
seen it and he paints jeffree star
Adrian Jeffrey in pure silver fox
I love Gandalf so I'm ready to get my
Gandalf glam on I watched it yesterday
and it seems difficult but manageable I
need to find a friendship with me first
day I'm going to pull my hair back kind
of like an arias groans I have happening
right now the one thing is Geoffrey star
does not have eyebrows so I'm going to
glue down my eyebrows I don't know
exactly how to do it kind of beautiful
already glad I got out of bed for this
so when I was prepping for this video
yesterday I went to the drugstore and
bought all drugstore products so this
entire looked as creative as drugstore
products talk about setting yourself up
to fail here look at those do another
layer I feel a little tag I saw that
Trixie Mattel said that you set your
eyebrows with setting powder when the
glue is still tacky so that the powder
sticks sticks to it well now I'm just
going to wipe away the excess powder I
feel like I made my eyebrows more lumpy
I'll do another layer I don't think this
is right it's always good to go into
these tutorials just feeling so insecure
oh no I have the powder everywhere I
mean these weren't my favorite leggings
or anything
Wow even better that just makes you work
sometimes we're all gonna die someday so
I try anything at all who don't ever put
yourself out there
my eyebrows you feel flattered and
crustier okay so she's going basically
above the socket line a new socket line
well okay now I'm going to turn Mac's
that on the other side her distressful
and soothing look I think I did ish
smudge that line husband will have an
infomercial on it 3a and Home Shopping
Network because she is all about
blending well oh god she'll never be my
friend now wait a minute wait a minute
missed that butter she brought this part
down what what color so it looks like
she takes like a slate gray and starts
shading that these two blue palettes one
is from Maybelline wanted some covergirl
three my name is this slight bluish
color here damn it quit an opening so
wheat from my illness feel bad for me
subscribe now she's just blending a
slight blue over this turquoise color
we're just blending that in over this it
looks like that did something cool good
all the glue is flaking off so if I
could just dry skin dry green yeah sure
okay so now she's not darker blue one of
these darker blues let's see which one
does following this line maybe that did
something here that some I'm sorry I
just thought it wasn't being as
obnoxious as I could in the video and
should use a darker blue in a darker
blue now dang girl
yeah well that's some done this side
feels like the psalmist sure this one
had a late night last night my favorite
highlight what what okay so I need white
powder to recreate the brow bone up
there but I don't have that kind of
white powder I'm going to use this white
pencil to recruiting the brow bone oh
hey there friend okay now I'm gonna burn
that in a little bit Oh same on the
other side
good thing I covered up my brush do you
know what that song was called it's
called health Wow something happening on
my face you guys that's what she said he
said he's using Geoffrey starts
turquoise lipstick on the eye and then
putting glitter over top of it honey
you're just turquoise - school again
he'll then in and then we put some white
glitter over top I have this Jesse's
girls litter and I'm just gonna stick on
this oh well hi okay okay I just look
like barf Wow
you sort of blend everything to get it a
little bit something is going on
now we're going on to do the face I have
all of these big foundations and I'm
going to try and use smooth to it this
one all over my face and then we blend
it in so awful I burn my forehead on a
curling iron I just if you wanted to
know how consistently and capable I am
you know what this book reminds me a
girl went to college and got her degree
now we're putting white underneath here
as a highlight see if this works
Wow like two beautiful Nike signs right
underneath your eyes not fun with this
Revlon highlighter illuminator thing on
top cause it's really shimmery remember
we're going for Gandalf glamour blend in
your highlight I don't think that did
anything good for me it is beautiful yet
now they are contouring I'm going to use
this darker foundation stick to start
contouring alright okay alright love
cuddley cheekbones in there she is
Cristobal to blend in the contour
[ __ ] I feel like this is not um oh
good job I'm cheating on my drugstore
haul I'm using this other Beauty Blender
all right what's next I don't have a
drugstore blush so I'm just using this
or from Stila
although I just look at myself in the
mirror and it looks way better on camera
than nothing person runs on the outward
in oh now they're doing highlight I
don't have a drugstore highlighter so
I'm going to use Becca shimmering skin
perfecter your oh what twice white tiger
what the [ __ ] is happen and as a missing
to this white and put it here and then
grated just like crazy line okay I got
no weird lines happening then what
happened let some dark blue in this line
let's just art bloom in this laughing
okay but did something I don't know yet
oh they took this liquid liner from Kat
Von D that I actually own picked rate
some stuff so I'm going to do that too
I've now for gone on the drugstore rule
but that wasn't going to be a rule
unless I said the rule so I didn't go to
all the rules I'm changing the rules I
know that makes you feel like nothing in
the world is in your control which is
just entirely true and they're all gonna
die someday
well I think I made a huge difference
not going to try and copy it on the
other side oh my god something happen
okay what next he puts them in here
alright that cousin there happened I put
white in between when I try this white
pencil see if it shows up more Hey now
he's drawing in the brow oh crap I've
drawn oh no oh man I can't draw eyebrows
I'm sure you guys already too only that
small my other videos and make these
eyebrows look more natural because this
look is all about natural soft look at
those eyebrows wow oh my god
she's putting blue lips for her huh
a blue lipstick let me check so the blue
lipstick so the blue lipstick might have
fallen out of my bag in my car but
there's no way I'm going out to my car
right now to look for it so we're going
to just see what we can use here why not
I'm using this liquid liner that I just
used and we're going to see what happens
salty and she blend it with a lighter
blue I had this other blue liquid and
she just blends them together with a
finger it really blends liquid liner
turns out Oh on your smell this time and
Fornell lashes off flat lashes thing
good news lashes on this'll be a goddamn
miracle though [ __ ] a typically said
for a second I get tacky like me and my
general aesthetic god damn it outside
was way easier she doubles them up I
can't
I'll a [ __ ] on the bottom I got these
individual lashes so it doesn't might be
easier to put individual lashes on the
bottom but we doubt it pretty busy Brown
finish this war and that's it we're done
Wow look at this
Gandalf glamour happening almost
identical to the look missing did on
jeffree star
there's a lot I don't think I did miss
fame any justice at all with us it did
drag me out of bed though
it's great to do videos like this
because it really lets me know I have
limitations but I can't do everything I
set my mind to practice makes time go by
if you liked this video let me know in
the comments down below and give it a
thumbs up let me know what other drag
looks I should try out in the future
because as shitty as this turned out
have a great time doing it it's not
about the destination it's about the
journey those people that never actually
get to their destination don't forget to
subscribe to this YouTube channel
because just quality stuff like this
that is important to the evolution of
humanity will continuously happen on
this channel and you want to make sure
that you are notified I don't have I
need my body have felt copyright cleanse
[ __ ]